Sylvia's parents are immigrants, very traditional. And in Sylvia's house, the men are men, the women are women, just like back in the old country.
西尔维亚的父母是移民，非常传统。在西尔维亚家里，男人就是男人，女人就是女人，就像在老家一样。
My brother goes, "Oh, I want tortillas." And my mom, just like right there on, she'll just turn off the TV and she'll go make them. And my brother goes, "I want money." And my mom's right there taking my money. He goes, "Wash this shirt for me. I want to wear it tomorrow." And there goes my mom, washing the shirt. And it's not like that with me.
我哥哥说：“哦，我想吃玉米饼。”然后我妈就会立刻关掉电视去给他做。我哥哥说：“我要钱。”我妈就在那儿拿我的钱给他。他说：“帮我洗这件衬衫，我明天要穿。”于是我妈就去洗衬衫了。但我可没这种待遇。
That's the way she thinks. That's the way she is. She's like, he's a boy. For instance, he can't cook for himself. He's a boy. He can't do this because he's a boy. That's a woman's job. My mom always has this little saying that really annoys me. Sometimes when the house is dirty, she says, "Oh, it looks like there's never been women in the house," making it sound like women are supposed to clean. And I'm thinking, Dad can clean. She goes, "No, he's supposed to be in the garage fixing the car or something."
她就是这么想的，她就是那样的人。她觉得，他是男孩，所以他不会做饭，他不能做这个，因为他是男孩。那是女人的活儿。我妈总挂在嘴边的一句话让我特别反感。有时候家里乱了，她会说：“噢，看来这家里从来没有过女人啊。”这话听起来就好像女人天生就该干家务似的。我心想，我爸也可以打扫啊。她说：“不行，他应该在车库修车什么的。”
It's a typical American story in this country. From the time she was little, Sylvia spoke English better than her parents. She was the one in the family who'd call the phone company or the utilities. She translated teacher conferences. If the family was going somewhere and needed directions, Sylvia was the one who would walk up to a stranger and ask for them. And now, nearly grown up, she wants to be an American girl in a way that her parents don't completely understand. She goes to a big, integrated public school. A few years ago, she started listening to The Cranberries and Nirvana and Metallica, not the kind of stuff her parents knew growing up in small towns in rural Mexico.
在这个国家，这是一个典型的美国故事。西尔维亚从小英语就比她父母好。家里要打给电话公司或水电局，都是她来联络。家长会由她来翻译。如果一家人出门需要问路，也是西尔维亚去向陌生人问路。如今，快要长大的她想成为一名美国女孩，但她的父母并不完全理解。她就读于一所大型的综合性公立学校。几年前，她开始听小红莓乐队、涅槃乐队和金属乐队的歌，这些可不是她父母在墨西哥农村小镇长大时听的那种音乐。
My mom wants me to be a typical Mexican girl. When I was younger, before I had my cotillion, I used to start liking alternative music.
我妈希望我成为一个典型的墨西哥女孩。我小时候，在举行成人礼之前，我开始喜欢上另类音乐。
Cotillion's like a coming out party when you turn 15.
成人礼就像你15岁时的社交首秀。
Yeah, when you turn 15. You have a huge party. You get your own beautiful dress. It's long, and it's big. I started liking alternative music around the age of 14, around the time they started making my cotillion. And I remember my cousins used to say, oh, as soon as you hit your cotillion, you're going to start liking Mexican music. And we're going to start taking you out. Because in my family, as soon as you hit 15, you're allowed to go to Mexican dances. But you usually go with your older cousins.
对，15岁的时候。你会举办一场盛大的派对。你会穿上属于你自己的漂亮裙子，裙子又长又大。我在14岁左右开始喜欢另类音乐，当时他们正准备为我举办成人礼。我记得我的表亲们总说，等你过了成人礼，你就会开始喜欢墨西哥音乐了，我们也会开始带你出去玩。因为在我们家，一到15岁，你就可以去参加墨西哥舞会了。但通常你是和年长的表亲一起去。
And that's where my mom wanted in me. My mom wanted me to be like my cousins. They went to Mexican dances. They had Mexican boyfriends. I mean, she wanted me to dress like them. She didn't want me to dress kind of alternative. And now sometimes we get into fights and I tell my mom, I'm not like my cousins. I'm like, my cousins are already like 19, 18, and they're already pregnant or married. I'm like, is that what you want me to do with my life?
我妈希望我成为那样的人。她希望我像我的表亲一样。她们会去参加墨西哥舞会，交墨西哥男朋友。我的意思是，她希望我的穿着打扮也像她们。她不希望我穿得那么另类。现在我们有时会吵架，我告诉她，我跟我的表亲不一样。我说，我的表亲们都已经18、19岁，不是怀孕就是结婚了。我说，这就是你希望我过的人生吗？
This weekend, this is a particularly urgent question in Sylvia's life. This weekend, January 31, 1998, Sylvia turns 18. She's legally recognized as an adult, capable of deciding for herself what she'll do with her life. And she and her mom have been talking about what she's going to do. Sylvia wants to go to a four year college, wait to get married, wait to have kids. And her mom is trying to understand.
这个周末，这对西尔维亚来说是一个特别紧迫的问题。这个周末，即1998年1月31日，西尔维亚就满18岁了。她在法律上被视为成年人，有能力决定自己的人生道路。她和她妈妈一直在讨论她未来要做什么。西尔维亚想上四年制大学，晚点结婚，晚点要孩子。而她妈妈正在努力去理解。
Sometimes she's kind of like, yeah, do what you want. Do what you want. Become whatever you want. And there's just times where, like, why do you want to do that? Why do you want to do that? Why do you think you're better than everybody? Why do you think you're special? I'm like, Ma, I don't think I'm special. I just want to do something with my life.
有时她会说，随你吧，做你想做的，成为你想成为的人。但有时她又会说，你为什么要那样做？你为什么要那样做？你为什么觉得自己比别人强？你为什么觉得自己很特别？我说，妈，我不觉得我特别，我只是想在人生中做点事情。
When her mom was young, back in Tamaulipas, her mom wanted to go to school. She was admitted to a good school nearby, but her grandfather told her no. He said the only reason the girls go to school is to get boyfriends. So she stopped going in sixth grade. Now she spends most of her time at home, raising Sylvia's brother and sister, taking care of the house, rarely leaving the house.
她妈年轻时在塔毛利帕斯州也想上学。她被附近一所好学校录取了，但她祖父不让去。他说女孩子上学唯一的目的就是交男朋友。于是她六年级就辍学了。现在她大部分时间都待在家里，照顾西尔维亚的弟弟妹妹，操持家务，很少出门。
My mom has lived in a box all her life, and I feel like a lot of Mexican women have. When you live in a box, you raise your children in a box. And sometimes I'll just try to climb out. And she's like pushing me in or I'm trying to poke a hole in the box and she tapes it right back up.
我妈一生都活在一个盒子里，我觉得很多墨西哥女性也是。当你活在一个盒子里，你养育孩子时也会让他们待在盒子里。有时我试着爬出来，她就把我推回去，或者我想在盒子上戳个洞，她马上又会把它封上。
Well, today on our radio program, Escaping the Box You were Born Into. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program in three acts. Act One, An American Girl Turns 18.
今天在我们的广播节目中，主题是《逃离你出生的盒子》。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《这就是美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带来各种相关的不同故事。今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，一位美国女孩年满18岁。
Act Two, $33 Million Box, the true story of a successful Cincinnati businessman millionaire who escaped his old life and created a new one in one single day by robbing a bank.
第二幕，3300万美元的盒子，讲述了一位成功的辛辛那提百万富翁商人，在一天之内通过抢劫银行，彻底逃离旧生活并开启新生活的真实故事。
Act Three, The Feeling You Want and the Feeling You Get. We have an excerpt from David Cale's funny and thrilling story of a middle-aged woman who escapes the box of her own life. Stay with us.
第三幕，你想要的感受与你得到的感受。我们节选了大卫·凯尔的一段有趣又惊心动魄的故事，讲述了一位中年女性如何逃离她自己生活的盒子。请继续收听。
Act One, American Girl Turns 18. So Sylvia is living at home, senior in high school, engaged in an ongoing discussion with her mom about what she should be after graduation in four months and whether she'll live a life like her mom's.
第一幕，美国女孩年满18岁。西尔维亚住在家里，是高三学生。她正和妈妈讨论毕业后该做什么，以及她是否会过上像她妈妈那样的生活。
She's too scared to get out of the box. She is. She even told me. She's just too scared. I mean, if she has to go to my godmother's house, all she has to do do is take one bus and go straight. And she just gets off at a certain stop and walks a block or two. That scares my mom that she's by herself. It scares the hell out of her being by herself. It just really scares her.
她太害怕走出那个盒子了。真的，她亲口对我说的。她就是太害怕了。我的意思是，如果她要去我教母家，她只需坐一趟直达公交车，然后在某一站下车走一两个街区就行。就这样，她妈妈都害怕独自出门。独自一人让她感到恐惧，真的让她非常害怕。
And I'm always by myself. And I'm always doing things by myself. And I'm always doing things that I want. And I think sometimes she admires me that I'm not scared, but at the same time, she just doesn't-- it's like she admires me that I'm not scared, but I think at the same time she hates me because she's scared.
而我总是独来独往。我总是独自做事情，做我想要做的事情。我觉得有时候她很佩服我没有恐惧感，但同时，我觉得她又恨我，因为她自己充满恐惧。
Describe the box that she's in.
描述一下她所处的那个盒子。
I would guess it's just the typical Mexican family, where you're married and you have children and you die together. And you travel once in a while to your homeland, and you have usually Mexican music and laughter and drinking and partying. And all the cousins coming together and all the aunts coming together.
我觉得那就是典型的墨西哥家庭，结婚、生子，然后一起老去。偶尔回故乡旅行，总是听着墨西哥音乐，欢笑、喝酒、聚会。所有的堂表亲聚在一起，所有的姑姨聚在一起。
Do you think she's unhappy? I mean, that sounds like it could be actually kind of nice.
你觉得她不快乐吗？听起来其实挺美好的。
Yeah, it could be nice, but, I mean, when you only hang around with that kind of people and that certain people and they're-- because they're kind of also-- not like bigots or something, but they're also really-- kind of like the way she thinks.
是啊，确实可能挺美好。但问题是，当你只和那种人、那种特定群体交往时——他们并不是偏执狂之类的，但他们确实……就像我妈那样思考。
Everybody thinks the same way.
每个人都以同样的方式思考。
And they're not so crazy about people who think differently.
而且他们对于想法不同的人不太包容。
Yeah, it's kind of like I'm the outcast of the family. I'm like the black sheep. That's why I really never depended on my parents because I really never had them when I wanted them. And also I never really asked for anything. I never really wanted anything from them. And now that I'm almost going to turn 18, they noticed that I really don't ask anything from them.
是啊，我就像是家里的局外人。我是那只“黑羊”。这就是为什么我从不依赖我的父母，因为当我需要他们的时候，他们从来不在。而且我从不向他们要求什么，我也不想要他们的东西。现在我快满18岁了，他们才发现我真的什么都没向他们索取过。
I remember one time. It's really specific. It happened last year. It just popped into my head. I remember that my grandparents come every summer. And all the uncles and aunts come to the house because our grandparents are there and stuff like that. And I was working, and when I came home, one of my aunts came. She's the second oldest in the family, and I find her really bitter. She's my aunt, and I love her and stuff like that, but she's really bitter. And she had told my mom that really got me mad. This woman who I talk to maybe once or twice a year. And because my mom was raised by this aunt-- she sees her as a mother figure, too-- she has a lot of respect for her. She told my mom that the day that I grew up, I'm going to be ashamed of my parents and especially of her because she has no education and because she's an immigrant of this country.
我还记得一件事，非常具体。那是去年发生的，突然浮现在我脑海里。我记得祖父母每年夏天都会来。所有的叔叔阿姨都会来家里，因为祖父母在。我当时在工作，回来时遇到了一位阿姨。她是家里第二大的长辈，我觉得她非常刻薄。她是我的阿姨，我也爱她之类的，但她真的很刻薄。她对我妈说了一些话，让我非常生气。那个女人我一年可能才说上一两次话。因为我妈是由这个阿姨抚养大的——她也把她看作母亲般的长辈——所以她非常尊重她。她对我妈说，等我长大了，我会以我的父母为耻，尤其是以她为耻，因为她没有受过教育，是个移民。
And I told my mom, how dare she say that? She knows nothing about me. Does she want me to become like her kids? Her oldest daughter got pregnant at 16. And her youngest son is kind of like a drifter. He really doesn't know what he does. And I'm like, this woman has the idea that I'm going to be ashamed of my mom because I'm going to have an education and because I'm going to have a career?
我对我妈说，她怎么敢这么说？她根本不了解我。她想让我变成她那样的孩子吗？她的大女儿16岁就怀孕了。她的小儿子是个流浪汉，根本不知道自己在干什么。我心想，这个女人竟然认为我会因为自己受过教育、有事业而以我的母亲为耻？
I suggest to Sylvia that her parents might understand her situation better than she acknowledges. After all, they themselves escaped the box of their own early lives, uprooted themselves from rural Mexico to inner city Chicago, to a country where they didn't even speak the language. Sylvia doesn't buy it.
我向西尔维亚指出，她的父母可能比她意识到的更了解她的处境。毕竟，他们自己也逃离了早年生活的盒子，从墨西哥农村移居到芝加哥市中心，来到一个连语言都不通的国家。西尔维亚不买账。
But as we talk, one of the most striking things is how there's still a part of her, the biggest part of her, that wants her parents to simply understand her and how she sees her own life. She still wants to be part of the family.
但在我们交谈时，最令人印象深刻的一点是，她内心深处仍有一部分——也是最大的一部分——希望父母能真正理解她以及她对生活的看法。她依然想成为家庭的一员。
It's like this, sometimes you usually see my mom and my brother talking and stuff like that, and they're goofing off. You see my little sister-- sorry.
就像这样，有时你会看到我妈和我哥哥在聊天什么的，他们就在那儿胡闹。你会看到我的小妹妹——对不起。
Do you want some water?
你想喝点水吗？
No, that's OK. Usually I see my little sister and my dad talking and playing. Or sometimes you see my mom and my little sister laughing and stuff like that. And I'm usually in another room doing my own thing. I usually never do anything with her.
不用，没关系。通常我会看到我的小妹妹和我爸爸在聊天玩耍。或者有时你会看到我妈和我小妹妹在那儿笑之类的。而我通常在另一个房间做我自己的事。我通常从不和她一起参与什么活动。
And do you feel like that's mostly your choice, that that's the way that you want it?
你觉得这主要是你自己的选择吗？是你想要的那种方式吗？
Sometimes I do because a lot of the things that they want me to do, I don't want to do. And it really hurts me that they're not really supportive. So I guess I just try to move myself away from them so they won't hurt me as much. But they don't understand that. They think I'm too strong to be hurt.
有时是的，因为很多他们想让我做的事情，我并不想做。而且他们不支持我，这让我很受伤。所以我猜我只是试着让自己远离他们，这样他们就不会伤害我那么深了。但他们不明白这一点。他们以为我坚强到不会受伤。
Yeah. Yeah, but I mean they're not right about that.
是的。是的，但他们在这点上错了。
No, they're not.
不，他们错了。
But getting out of the box doesn't necessarily mean you're any happier. There are plenty of people who start off in a life that's really in a box and get out of it and change all the time. And that doesn't necessarily mean you're going to be happy.
但逃离盒子并不一定意味着你更快乐。有很多人起初过着像在盒子里一样的生活，后来跳了出来，生活也发生了改变。但这并不意味着你一定会幸福。
Yeah.
是的。
You can be happy in the box or out of the box.
无论在盒子里还是盒子外，你都可以快乐。
It all depends on how you feel.
这完全取决于你自己的感受。
Do you have a sense of what kind of job you might want to yet?
你对自己将来想做什么样的工作有头绪了吗？
I have an idea. I want this job that-- because I want to do digital effects, special digital effects.
我有想法。我想要那种……因为我想做数字特效，特殊的数字特效。
Like for movies and stuff.
就像电影特效之类的？
Yeah, like Jurassic Park and Men in Black and stuff like that. I think it's so cool. I just want one day to have a job. I usually think of myself sitting, having not like an office to myself but usually have an open space with a lot of different equipment everywhere and sitting in front of the computer and doing all these things on the computer and animating. And getting really frustrated because it takes me like six months to do like a five-second little scene. It's just doing my own thing, not have to get dressed up, go casual, have an eyebrow ring or something on, how my hair whatever color I want, have a real cool boss. But that's just a dream.
对，就像《侏罗纪公园》、《黑衣人》那样的。我觉得酷毙了。我梦想有一天能有份工作。我脑海里的场景是：不是一个人在封闭办公室里，而是一个有很多不同设备的大开间，我坐在电脑前，做着各种电脑动画。因为做一个五秒钟的小片段可能需要六个月而感到非常沮丧。我只想做我自己的事，不用刻意打扮，穿休闲装，戴个眉钉，头发染成任何我喜欢的颜色，有个超酷的老板。但这只是个梦想。
Have you seen those specials on TV where they show here's how they make these special effects and you see the people and what they look like who do all that work?
你看过电视上的那些特辑吗？就是展示这些特效是怎么制作的，你也能看到从事这些工作的人长什么样。
I've seen the making of Jurassic Park and Titanic and the Space Jam . And that's what I want to do, just use my imagination and make this thing blow up or something.
我看过《侏罗纪公园》、《泰坦尼克号》和《太空大灌篮》的幕后制作。那就是我想做的，只靠想象力去创造，让某个东西爆炸什么的。
What's your biggest fear in trying to get out of the box?
你在尝试逃离盒子时，最大的恐惧是什么？
Failing. That's my biggest fear is failing. Because I've done so many things. I've done so many organizations. I've done so many clubs. I did all these classes and all these grades. And it's just going to go to waste. That's my biggest fear that it's going to go to waste, that all that I did is going to amount to nothing.
失败。我最大的恐惧就是失败。因为我做了太多事情。我参加过那么多组织，进过那么多社团。我完成了所有的课程，拿到了所有的分数。这一切如果付诸东流……我最大的恐惧就是这些努力全都白费，我做的一切最终变得一文不值。
And if you failed, what would it be? Like what would you be?
如果你失败了，会怎样？比如你会变成什么样？
What would be my failure?
什么才算我的失败？
What would happen to you? Yeah.
你会发生什么？对。
I would become working an $11 an hour job at like 25 with already two kids and a husband and just doing that, day by day doing the same thing over and over.
我可能会在25岁时做着时薪11美元的工作，已经有了两个孩子和一个丈夫，日复一日地重复着同样的生活。
And what could make you fail?
什么会导致你失败？
I don't know. Sometimes I feel like my ambition's going to die out. It's kind of like you rebel against everybody because you think you know what you're doing and you know you want to achieve more and you want to do more. But every time you take another step, it just hits you right in  the face like, ha, ha, ha, you can't do it. Go back into your line. And after a while, you just get really tired of all the closing of the doors and telling you, no, you can't do this. And you're like, well, maybe they are right. One day I'll just get tired and I'll just say, you win.
不知道。有时我觉得我的野心会磨灭。这就像是你反抗所有人，因为你觉得你知道自己在干什么，你想取得更多成就，想做更多事。但每当你向前迈进一步，现实就会迎面给你一击，仿佛在说：哈哈，你做不到的，回到你的队伍里去吧。过了一段时间，你就会对那些不断关上的门感到厌倦，所有人都告诉你“不，你不能做这个”。然后你就会想，也许他们是对的。总有一天我会厌倦，然后说：你们赢了。
And do you feel like if you don't get out by the time you're 22 or 23 or 24, it's probably at that's when it would all die, like that's when your ambition would die and you would stay?
你觉得如果你在22岁、23岁或24岁之前没有走出去，那个时候野心就会磨灭，然后你就留下了吗？
Yeah, unless I change or something, unless all of a sudden something happens and my parents are supportive. And I don't get into fights as much anymore and I feel like I'm actually wanted around the house or something, and then I feel like I'm happy, like I'm actually happy to be home. Then I wouldn't mind, but I just hope that when I actually do achieve what I want, that is, I want them to say, yeah, she did it. She did it. I guess I was wrong.
是的，除非我改变了，或者突然发生了什么事，让我父母变得支持我。如果我不再跟他们吵架，觉得家里欢迎我，觉得回家的感觉真好，那我可能也不会介意。但我只希望当我真的实现了梦想时，他们能说：是的，她做到了，她真的做到了。我想我之前错了。
Sylvia turns 18 this weekend. Happy birthday. Good luck.
西尔维亚这个周末就满18岁了。生日快乐，祝你好运。
Act Two. You know who it's been a hard week for? It's been a hard week to be an intern. In fact, you could reasonably argue that in the history of interns, this past week or two, in late January 1998, they have been the low point. An intern here at WBEZ Chicago, home of This American Life , told me that she was waiting for the L train this week. And she's standing there, and this guy strikes up a conversation. And they're talking about this and that. And he says to her at some point, so what do you do? And she tells him that she's an intern. And he says, oh, really? As if she'd just told him, my job, I'm a slut. That's my job.
第二幕。你知道谁这周过得很艰难吗？做实习生这一周太难了。事实上，你完全可以说，在实习生历史上，1998年1月底的这两周简直是低谷。在WBEZ芝加哥（《这就是美国生活》的诞生地），一位实习生告诉我，她这周在等地铁，站着的时候，有个男人过来搭讪。他们聊着聊着，男人问她：“你是做什么的？”她告诉他自己是实习生。男人说：“哦，真的吗？”那语气简直就像她说的是：“我的工作是当荡妇。”
Our senior editor Paul Tough was once an intern. I started in public radio as an intern at National Public Radio in Washington 19 years ago. In fact, I would not have escaped the box that I grew up in if not for that internship. I would not be in radio at all. We at This American Life are a staff of former interns. Producers Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, Julie Snyder, all former interns. And so, to strike a small blow for the dignity of interns everywhere in this dire, dire hour our own This American Life intern, the capable and serious-minded Rachel Day will introduce our next act here on the program.
我们的资深编辑保罗·塔夫曾是一名实习生。我19年前在华盛顿的国家公共广播电台开始做实习生。事实上，如果不是那次实习，我根本无法逃离我长大的那个盒子。我根本不会进入广播行业。我们《这就是美国生活》全员都是前实习生。制片人阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·斯奈德，都是前实习生。所以，为了在这一严峻的时刻为全世界实习生的尊严做出一点微薄的贡献，我们《这就是美国生活》那位能力出众、认真负责的实习生瑞秋·戴，将为大家介绍本节目的下一幕。
Welcome to the show, Rachel.
欢迎来到节目组，瑞秋。
Thank you, Ira.
谢谢，艾拉。
OK. You ready to do this?
好的。准备好了吗？
I think so.
我想是的。
All right. Here we go. Here's the keys to the radio show. Drive safe. Bring it back home in one piece.
好吧。开始吧。这是节目的控制权。开车小心点，把它完整地带回来。
I think we're ready to go.
我想我们准备好了。
Act Two, $33 Million Box. Barry Miller didn't have the kind of life you'd think he'd want to escape. He owned a clothing store in Cincinnati that was worth $33 million. He could buy whatever he wanted, took $15,000 vacations with his family. But he was unhappy. And one day, he permanently escaped his old life and entered his new one with one simple and unorthodox act. He robbed a bank. Alex Blumberg talked with him at the Hocking Correctional Facility in Nelsonville, Ohio.
第二幕，3300万美元的盒子。巴里·米勒的生活其实并不像那种你想逃离的生活。他在辛辛那提拥有一家价值3300万美元的服装店。他可以买任何他想要的东西，带家人去进行1.5万美元的度假。但他不快乐。有一天，他通过一个简单且离经叛道的行为，彻底逃离了旧生活，进入了新生活。他抢劫了一家银行。亚历克斯·布隆伯格在俄亥俄州尼尔森维尔的霍金管教所采访了他。
If you ask Barry Miller what was wrong with making lots of money, he'll tell you this. He used to go to Rome at least twice a year, but he never saw the Coliseum. He never went to the Vatican. If his business was over in the morning, he'd find a flight back in the afternoon. He was driven. His relationship with his family suffered.
如果你问巴里·米勒赚大钱有什么问题，他会告诉你这个：他过去每年至少去两次罗马，但他从来没看过斗兽场。他从来没去过梵蒂冈。如果早晨生意处理完了，他下午就会找航班回去。他就是这么拼。他与家人的关系很糟糕。
In Dallas once, I was with my oldest son, my middle child. And I never spent a lot of time with him. I would try to go to his soccer games or those kinds of things, but I never really made it on time. I got there at the last quarter.
有一次在达拉斯，我和我的大儿子、二儿子在一起。我从没花太多时间陪他们。我会试着去参加他们的足球比赛之类的，但我从没准时赶到过。我到的时候通常已经是最后一节了。
So we were out. We were driving around. And here I am with my son, and I have so very little to talk to him about and so little that I can relate with him about. We started talking about cars. And so I thought, well, he's interested in cars. Let's go buy a car. So I went to buy a car. We bought a car. Didn't need a car. I could afford to buy a car. We went to buy a car.
所以我们当时开车到处逛。我和我儿子在一起，却发现几乎无话可谈，没什么共同点。我们开始聊车。我想，好吧，他对车感兴趣。那我们去买辆车吧。于是我去买车。我们买了一辆车。根本不需要车。我买得起车。我们就去买了。
Looking back, he says he was shallow and vain. He says he was worshiping false gods. At the time though, he only felt a vague nagging that something wasn't right. But he says gradually that feeling became more insistent and took stranger forms. For instance, he says, he started blacking out, losing hours in the day.
回过头来看，他说他当时肤浅又虚荣。他说他在崇拜伪神。但当时，他只是感到一种隐约的、挥之不去的预感，觉得什么地方不对劲。他说这种感觉逐渐变得更加强烈，并以奇怪的形式表现出来。例如，他说他开始断片，一天里会丢失好几个小时的时间。
I was in New York on business, and I lost an afternoon. I didn't really know where I was, what I was doing. I ended up finding myself sitting in a lounge in a building that I recall going into because I had some business to do there, but it was three hours later. I don't know what I did for those three hours.
我在纽约出差，丢失了一个下午的时间。我真的不知道我在哪里，在做什么。最后我发现自己坐在一个休息室里，那是某个我记得自己进去办过事的大楼，但那是三个小时之后了。我不知道那三个小时里我做了什么。
Sometimes you actually make a real decision to change your life and you set about doing it. But just as often, you find yourself sort of edging toward the new life, half consciously. Part of you goes on as you always have while another part secretly plots an ambush. Barry Miller's case is as extreme as you can get. When he describes what happened, it's like he's describing a person in a trance.
有时你真的会做一个改变生活的决定，并着手去做。但同样常见的是，你会半自觉地朝着新生活走去。你的一部分像往常一样生活，而另一部分却在暗中策划伏击。巴里·米勒的情况是极端中的极端。当他描述发生的事情时，就像是在描述一个处于恍惚状态的人。
The day before the bank robbery, I drove by a car rental place. And I stopped. And I rented a car. Now, I have two cars, one I used and one my wife used. I rented a car. I really don't know why I rented the car, but I rented the car.
抢劫银行的前一天，我开车经过一家汽车租赁处。我停下来，租了一辆车。我有两辆车，一辆我用，一辆我妻子用。我租了一辆车。我真的不知道为什么要租车，但我就是租了。
And I continued on my way home, and I recall that we were out of fax paper. And I drive by a Sam's, which is where we used to get our fax paper from. And Sam's is on the right side of the road, and on the left side of the road is a Kmart. So I'm headed toward Sam's to get the fax paper, and I turn into the Kmart lot instead of the Sam's lot. And I bought a ski mask. And this is September, so they're not really out for sale. And I had ski masks at home. I bought a ski mask, and I know I bought the ski mask because at some point in time I come to and I'm sitting in the car and here I have a package with a ski mask in it.
我继续往家开，记起传真纸用完了。我开车经过一家萨姆会员店，以前我们就是在那买传真纸。萨姆会员店在路右侧，左侧是凯马特。我本来要去萨姆会员店买纸，结果却转进了凯马特的停车场。我在那买了一个滑雪面罩。当时是九月份，还没到卖这个的时候。家里明明有滑雪面罩。我买了一个，我知道我买了，因为我在某个时刻清醒过来，坐在车里，手里拿着一个装着滑雪面罩的包裹。
So you don't remember buying it?
所以你不记得买它了？
I don't remember buying it, but I know I bought it.
我不记得买的过程，但我知道我买了。
The next day, I get up. And I put into my briefcase a gun and a box of bullets. And regress a bit. I bought this gun on June 16 of '95. That would have been 15 months before I used it. I bought the gun because I was going to commit suicide. I had taken the gun. We had a balcony on this condo. And I took the gun one night, and I shot it into the woods. I had never shot a gun in my life. I wanted to know how I felt because I figured if I'm going to put it to my head, I wanted to know where to put it.
第二天，我起床。在公文包里放了一把枪和一盒子弹。往回说一下，这把枪是我在1995年6月16日买的。那是我使用它的15个月前。买枪是因为我想自杀。我拿了枪。当时公寓有个阳台。一天晚上我拿枪对着森林开了一枪。我这辈子没开过枪。我想知道感觉如何，因为如果我要对着自己的头开枪，我想知道该对着哪儿。
15 months later, I get the gun, put it in my briefcase. I leave. And from there I don't really remember exactly what happened. I don't know how I got to the bank. I don't know how I picked that bank or that location. I don't recall specific incidences.
15个月后，我带上枪，放进公文包。我出发了。从那以后我不记得具体发生了什么。不知道怎么到的银行。不知道怎么选的那家银行或那个地点。我不记得具体的细节。
Do you remember what you said to the teller? Do you remember?
你记得对柜员说了什么吗？你记得吗？
Not exactly. She said at the trial that I said something, give me all of your money, typical what you see in movies. I don't really remember. She said, give me all your money. She hadn't given me all of the money, and I said, all of it or something like that. I really don't remember. What I remember is only from what she said at the trial.
不完全记得。她在审判时说我说了些话，比如“把钱都给我”，就像电影里看到的那样。我真的记不清了。她说我说“把钱都给我”。她没把钱全部给我，我就说“全部”。我真的不记得了。我记得的只是她在审判时说的那些。
When he robbed the bank, he was earning well into six figures a year. His take from the robbery, $8,000. It's a lot to swallow, really, rob a bank, then claim not to remember it, especially when you bought a ski mask and rented a car the day before. And it's possible that Miller made up the story about not remembering when he went to trial.
抢劫银行时，他每年的收入高达六位数。他从抢劫中得手了8000美元。这真的很难让人接受，抢劫银行，然后声称不记得了，尤其是在前一天还买了滑雪面罩和租了车的情况下。米勒在受审时可能编造了关于失忆的故事。
He plead innocent by reason of insanity. The judge didn't buy it. I talked to Steve Tolbert, the prosecutor in Miller's criminal trial. He says it's possible that Miller was in a kind of a haze when he robbed the bank. He'd certainly never heard that defense before. But for Tolbert, it was immaterial. Either way, Miller was guilty of the crime.
他以精神错乱为由进行无罪辩护。法官没信。我采访了米勒刑事审判的检察官史蒂夫·托尔伯特。他说米勒抢劫时可能确实处于一种恍惚状态。他以前确实没听过这种辩护。但对托尔伯特来说，这无关紧要。无论如何，米勒都犯了罪。
But even Tolbert questions why a man who could have gotten a substantial loan from any bank in the city would actually need to hold one up for money. And more importantly, why would he have bungled the job so badly? When Miller lays out the facts, it's hard to believe this workaholic, super achiever was really trying to get away with it.
但连托尔伯特都质疑，一个可以在城里任何银行获得大额贷款的人，为什么要真的去抢银行？更重要的是，他为什么把事情搞得这么糟？当米勒列出事实时，很难相信这个工作狂、超级成就者真的想逃脱法律制裁。
Again, if this was a robbery to really get some money, I got to think I would have selected a place that wasn't on a busy street, a busy corner with a police station two blocks away. But in any event, my most vivid memories are after the bank robbery, where here I am, walking down the street that's relatively busy. The parking lot to the bank where I parked my car is in the back. I mean, I didn't even park in front. I had to walk a quarter of a block to get to the car. And I'm walking with a gun in my hand and a mask on my face at whatever time that was in the morning. It wasn't Halloween.
再说一遍，如果这是为了弄点钱而进行的抢劫，我肯定会选一个不在繁华街道，不在警察局隔壁两个街区的地方。但无论如何，我最深刻的记忆是在抢劫银行之后，我就走在一条相对繁忙的街道上。我停车的银行停车场在后边。我的意思是，我甚至都没停在正门。我得走过四分之一个街区才能到车那儿。我手里拿着枪，脸上戴着面具，不管那是早上的几点。又不是万圣节。
The police came relatively quickly. The bag that had the money in it, the dye thing exploded. This big cop with a gun is yelling at me, get down on the ground, get down on the ground. I really didn't totally comprehend all of what he was saying, but I eventually did. And I got down on the ground. And he handcuffed me, put me into his car, and took me away.
警察来得相当快。钱袋里的染色包爆炸了。那个拿着枪的高大警察朝我大喊，趴下，趴在地上。我并没有完全理解他说的所有话，但我最终明白了。我趴在了地上。他给我戴上手铐，把我塞进车里，带走了。
I'm no longer a rich man. I'm no longer a society person. I'm no longer the person that I was before. I killed that person. I can create this person that I now want to be. I can create a person who has more compassion, a person who wants a different lifestyle, who wants to live a different way. I lived on the top of the hill. I want to live in the valley with everybody else now.
我不再是个有钱人。我不再是社会名流。我不再是以前的那个人了。我杀了那个人。我可以创造我现在想成为的那个人。我可以创造一个更有同情心的人，一个想要不同生活方式、想要以不同方式生活的人。我曾经住在山顶，现在我想和大家一起住在山谷里。
A guy in my position, coming from my socioeconomic background does not do what I did. You don't go and rob a bank. So therefore I have now been cast out from my family. And that which they needed from me, I guess I can't give to them. That which I was supposed to be, I'm now an embarrassment, which is rather remarkable because frankly I now am happier with myself as a person than I was during all of that time.
像我这样社会经济背景的人是不会做这种事的。你不会去抢银行。所以我现在被家人抛弃了。我想他们需要我提供的那些东西，我可能给不了了。至于我本该成为的那个人，我现在成了羞耻。这非常值得关注，因为坦白说，比起那段日子，我现在作为一个人的自我感觉反而更快乐。
This is maybe the hardest thing of all to swallow. Talking to Miller, I got a familiar feeling. He sounded like a new convert to a religion or a junkie who's gone clean, like someone desperate to believe what he is saying is true. And who can blame him? When Barry Miller gets out of jail in four years, he's going to have to rebuild a life from scratch. No family, no job, 68 years old. Despite my doubts, I wanted to believe him too.
这可能是最难接受的事情。和米勒交谈时，我有一种熟悉的感觉。他听起来像是一个刚皈依宗教的人，或者是戒了毒的瘾君子，像是一个迫切想相信自己所说的是真话的人。谁又能怪他呢？当巴里·米勒四年后出狱时，他将不得不从零开始重建生活。没有家庭，没有工作，68岁了。尽管我有疑虑，但我还是想相信他。
Alex Blumberg is a writer in Chicago.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是芝加哥的一名作家。
So Rachel, want to take us to the ID break?
那么，瑞秋，想带我们进入身份识别间歇吗？
Yeah.
好。
Coming up, lizards, awkwardness, and falling in love from Public Radio International. That's in a minute when our program continues.
接下来，蜥蜴、尴尬和坠入爱河，来自国际公共广播电台。稍后节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Rachel Day, the intern here at This American Life. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to take a whack at that them. Today's show, Escaping the Box of Your Own life. We've arrived at Act Three, The Feeling You Want and the Feeling You Get.
这里是《这就是美国生活》。我是瑞秋·戴，这里的实习生。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目主题是《逃离你生活的盒子》。我们进入了第三幕，《你想要的感受与你得到的感受》。
Rachel, that was such a good job.
瑞秋，你做得太棒了。
Good.
太好了。
You are a credit to interns everywhere.
你是全世界实习生的荣誉。
I am so glad.
我太高兴了。
In this, their darkest hour.
在他们最黑暗的时刻。
That's right.
没错。
In this act we have a story from David Cale from a show that premiered here at the Goodman Theatre here in Chicago. And in this show, David Cale comes out on stage in black jeans and a corduroy shirt. And without dressing as a woman or changing his voice in any way, he simply becomes this middle-aged, good-humored British woman named Lillian.
在这一幕中，我们有一个来自大卫·凯尔的故事，选自他在芝加哥古德曼剧院首演的一场演出。在这场演出中，大卫·凯尔穿着黑牛仔裤和灯芯绒衬衫走上舞台。他没有装扮成女人，也没有改变声音，只是简单地变身为一名叫莉莲的中年、风趣的英国女性。
The story he tells is of how Lillian escapes the life she's in. She launches herself out of her old life in this kind of half trance, like the bank robber we heard from earlier but not quite so severe. Lillian take steps to destroy her own life while she's only kind of half conscious that that's exactly what is it that she's trying to do. And the incident that gets her out of her old life turns out to be so small and awkward and a bit disappointing, but it does the job.
他讲述了莉莲如何逃离她所处的生活。她像我们刚才听到的那个银行抢劫犯一样，以一种半恍惚的状态将自己从旧生活中抛了出去，虽然没那么极端。莉莲采取行动毁掉自己的生活，但她只是半清醒地知道这正是她想要做的。而让她走出旧生活的事件，结果竟然是那么微小、尴尬，甚至有点令人失望，但它确实起到了作用。
Before we begin this story, a quick warning that there's some sexual content in the story. No nasty words and, of course, nothing as graphic as the network news this week, but some mild sexual content that might not be appropriate for some younger listeners.
在故事开始前，预警一下，故事中有一些性内容。没有脏话，当然也没有本周电视新闻中那么露骨，但会有一些轻微的性内容，可能不适合年幼的听众。
The thought of someone else inside you is something I could never come to terms with. Keith had said to me before he went up north on that job, "I could get over somebody kissing you or cuddling, but if someone else went inside, I don't think I could ever touch you again." "Don't be dramatic," I said. "Nobody's going anywhere with me." Then almost a minute, the door shut. Keith was hardly in his precious Volvo when I meet little Jimmy in the store, 15 years my junior, with a look on his face the could drag a shipwreck up from the bottom of the ocean. "Wipe that dirty look off your face, Jimmy Foyle," I said, "and stop trying to put your fingers in my mouth. I'm a married woman."
想到有别人进入你的身体，是我永远无法接受的事。基思在去北方出差前曾对我说：“如果有人吻你或拥抱你，我或许能接受，但如果有人进入过你，我想我再也无法碰你了。”“别演了，”我说，“谁会跟我发生什么。”不到一分钟，门就关上了。基思刚开着他那辆珍贵的沃尔沃离开，我就在店里遇到了小吉米，他比我小15岁，脸上那表情简直能把沉船从海底捞出来。“擦掉你脸上那副肮脏的表情，吉米·福伊尔，”我说，“别再想把手指伸进我嘴里了。我是个已婚女人。”
I couldn't believe the words were coming out of me. It was like my husband just flew out the window. Jimmy was really what I had in mind for a lover before I said yes to Keith. He was. He was the kind of person I always wanted when I was his age but who never seemed interested in me. I wasn't generally a Jimmy's type. Jimmys didn't generally take notice of women like me. We seemed too tame. Jimmy was a wild one. Rough around the edges, he was a bit of a devil. Didn't give things a lot of thought the way Keith did. And he was funny. Keith had nothing approaching a sense of humor. Actually, Keith was the only person I knew that didn't find me funny in any way.
我简直不敢相信这些话竟然出自我的口中。就好像我丈夫刚才飞出了窗外。吉米其实就是我在答应基思之前心目中的理想情人。他确实是。他是我在那个年纪一直想要、但似乎从未对我感兴趣的那种人。我通常不是吉米的那种类型。吉米通常不会注意我这种女人。我们看起来太温顺了。吉米是个野孩子。性格粗犷，有点像个小恶魔。不像基思那样凡事想那么多。而且他很有趣。基思是我认识的人中唯一觉得我一点都不好笑的人。
"I can't believe that, Lillian," Jimmy said. "You're a riot." "Oh, how refreshing," I thought, "to be found funny again." It was really the idea of a Jimmy coming along that kept me from completely giving over to Keith. I've been holding out for the thought of a Jimmy for a long time. So when he aimed his eyes at me and came on so strong that day, something in me was saying, it would not be a good idea to turn Jimmy down. It'll be a little fling.
“我真不敢相信，莉莲，”吉米说，“你太逗了。”“哦，太令人耳目一新了，”我心想，“我又被人觉得有趣了。”正是吉米出现的想法，让我没有完全向基思妥协。我一直暗暗期待着一个像吉米这样的人。所以那天他盯着我，攻势如此猛烈时，我内心有一个声音在说：拒绝吉米可不是个好主意。就当是一次小小的情感外遇吧。
You have to work out this Jimmy thing. Lillian, it's between you and yourself. Jimmy knew Keith was out of town. I think he'd even been watching the precious Volvo to see if it was still in the front. He invited me over to his house to see his lizards. "Lizards?" I said. "Yes, lizards," he said. "How peculiar," I said. "All right, Jimmy."
你得处理好吉米这件事。莉莲，这是你和你自己的事。吉米知道基思不在镇上。我想他甚至一直盯着那辆珍贵的沃尔沃看它还在不在门口。他邀请我去他家看他的蜥蜴。“蜥蜴？”我说。“是的，蜥蜴，”他说。“真奇怪，”我说，“好吧，吉米。”
He drove his car like he just robbed the bank. We ran a red light. "Hold on to your seat, Lillian," I thought. His car didn't have safety belts. "I cut them off," he said. "They were uncomfortable." I thought about Keith. Keith wouldn't start the engine unless everyone was strapped in.
他开车的样子就像刚刚抢了银行。我们闯了红灯。“抓紧你的座位，莉莲，”我想。他的车没装安全带。“我割掉了，”他说，“它们不舒服。”我想到基思。基思如果不让所有人都系好安全带，是不会发动引擎的。
Jimmy's house was lined with tiny aquariums. He got all excited as he told me what the various lizards were and where they came from. He was quite the authority. Outside of the store, he looked much younger. "God, Lillian," I thought, "what are you doing?"
吉米的房子里摆满了小水族箱。他很兴奋地告诉我各种蜥蜴是什么、产自哪里。他简直是个专家。店外面的他看起来年轻多了。“天哪，莉莲，”我想，“你在干什么？”
When he made his move on me, it was so sudden. Talk about a pounce. Even the lizards scuttled behind their plastic rocks. I immediately felt like I'd been thrown into a wrestling ring. As we were rolling around on his leopard blanket, I must confess, my first thought was, "Am I really enjoying this?" He was so rough and young. There was no warming up with Jimmy. In fact, much to my surprise, it was dreadful.
当他向我扑过来时，那真是太突然了。简直是猛扑。连蜥蜴都躲到了塑料岩石后面。我立刻觉得自己像被扔进了摔跤场。我们在他那条豹纹毯子上翻滚时，我必须承认，我第一个念头是：“我真的在享受这个吗？”他太粗鲁也太年轻了。吉米没有任何热身过程。事实上，令我非常惊讶的是，这太糟糕了。
It's funny, I realized I'd gotten used to Keith's mouth. Jimmy had a smaller mouth. I think Keith's tongue was wider, too. There was nothing sensual about Jimmy's tongue. It just sort of flickered around in my mouth, like the tongues of one of those lizards of his.
真有趣，我意识到我已经习惯了基思的嘴。吉米的嘴更小。我觉得基思的舌头也更宽。吉米的舌头一点感官刺激都没有。它只是在我嘴里闪来闪去，就像他那些蜥蜴的舌头一样。
Whatever was wrong with Keith, the sexual part was all right. Or maybe I'd overrated it, but he was considerate. Sexually speaking, I'd say Keith was like a really good waiter in a pretty good restaurant. Very good service but ultimately disappointing food.
基思不管有什么问题，性这方面还是可以的。也许是我高估了它，但他很体贴。从性方面来说，基思就像一家还不错的餐馆里非常好的服务员。服务很好，但食物最终还是令人失望。
Jimmy seemed to approach the whole thing like it was some form of kung fu or that I was something that needed to be overthrown. But believe me, I was just laying there. He was nervous, bless him. I tried to get him to ease up. "Slow down," I said, in a voice that was supposed to sound seductive. But I have to admit, it did come out rather motherly. Then he breathed into my ear. "Can I [BLEEP] you, Lillian?" I thought about Keith, what the thought of someone else being inside me would do to him, how it really would be the final straw. And I said, "Yes, Jimmy. If you want."
吉米对待整件事的方式好像它是某种功夫，或者我是什么需要被征服的东西。但相信我，我只是躺在那儿。他很紧张，老天保佑他。我试着让他放松点。“慢点，”我用一种本该诱惑的语调说。但我不得不承认，听起来确实更像是母亲的叮嘱。然后他对着我的耳朵呼吸。“莉莲，我可以搞你吗？”我想到基思，想到如果有别人进入我的身体他会有什么反应，那真的会成为压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。我说：“可以，吉米。如果你想要的话。”
What follows is a brief scene that's too graphic to play for you on the radio. Let's just say things take awhile. Jimmy keeps his eyes scrunched shut. Lillian keeps hers open, lays there thinking about her husband, staring at the aquarium.
接下来是一个简短的场景，过于露骨，不便在电台播出。我们只能说事情花了一些时间。吉米一直紧闭双眼。莉莲一直睁着眼，躺在那儿想着丈夫，盯着水族箱。
And I'm looking at Jimmy's lizards. Can they really be happy in those little tanks with a light bulb over their heads morning and night? And he took so long. [YAWNS] It is starting to feel a little like a visit to the dentist more than a sexual fling.
我看着吉米的蜥蜴。它们在那充满电灯泡、日夜明亮的小水箱里真的快乐吗？他花了太长时间。（打哈欠）这开始感觉更像是看牙医，而不是什么性外遇。
Then Jimmy makes a noise like he's been shot in the leg. And I realize, "Thank God." He rolls over to the other side of the blanket. "That was sexy," he says. "Yes," I said. "It was very. Thank you." Lillian, polite to the end.
然后吉米发出了一声像腿部中弹的声音。我意识到，“谢天谢地。”他翻身滚到毯子的另一边。“那很性感，”他说。“是的，”我说，“是非常。谢谢。”莉莲，自始至终彬彬有礼。
But then Jimmy did some really sweet things. He ran a bath, put something blue in the water. He showed me his muscles. "Ooh," I said. He lit candles. He was quite romantic after all. He was a boy, really. I half expected the police to come barging in and arrest me.
但后来吉米做了些非常贴心的事。他放了热水，在水里加了些蓝色的东西。他向我展示了他的肌肉。“哦，”我说。他点燃了蜡烛。他毕竟还是挺浪漫的。他确实还是个孩子。我甚至半是期待警察闯进来逮捕我。
"Did I disappoint you?" he asked. "No, of course not," I said. And for a moment, he looked so vulnerable, I thought my heart would break.
“我让你失望了吗？”他问。“没有，当然没有，”我说。有一瞬间，他看起来如此脆弱，我觉得我的心都要碎了。
We sat in the bath. He was behind me. He did my back. Drew objects on my shoulders in soap and had me guess what they were. "It's a giraffe," I said. "No, it's a crane," he said. "You win," I said. He was laughing. He looked even younger with his hair wet.
我们坐在浴缸里。他在我身后。他帮我擦背。用肥皂在我的肩膀上画东西让我猜是什么。“是长颈鹿，”我说。“不对，是起重机，”他说。“你赢了，”我说。他在笑。头发湿漉漉的他看起来更年轻了。
And I'm thinking of Keith in these Volvo, following the taillights of another car with his radio on-- he probably near Scotland by then-- with that perpetually anxious look on his face that he inherited from his father. And they're both nice men. I mean, sweet men, good people.
我正想着基思开着沃尔沃，跟着另一辆车的尾灯，收音机开着——他当时可能已经快到苏格兰了——脸上带着那种从他父亲那里遗传来的、永恒的焦虑表情。他们都是好男人。我是说，贴心的男人，好人。
And as the damn television is chattering away in the background, all I can think is, "Well, my dear, now what?"
背景里电视机嘈杂声响个不停，我唯一能想到的就是：“嗯，亲爱的，现在该怎么办？”
Now we skip ahead five years. Lillian is out of her marriage, working in a bookstore. She decides to go away to Brighton for a little vacation.
现在我们跳过五年。莉莲已经离婚，在一家书店工作。她决定去布莱顿度个假。
Well, I was walking along the front, past the chalets on the beach when I hear somebody calling my name. I turned around and see this young man with a beard waving at me. "Who on Earth are you," I thought. I presumed it must be a customer from the store. "It's me," said the man with the beard. "It's Jimmy. Don't you remember?" "Jimmy," I cried, totally taken aback, "You look completely different. I would have walked right past you." Besides the beard, he was much slimmer. And it's probably my imagination, but I think he'd grown.
那天我正沿着海滩前面的小木屋走，突然听到有人喊我的名字。我转过身，看到一个留着胡子的年轻人向我招手。“你是谁啊，”我心想。我猜这大概是店里的顾客。“是我，”那个留胡子的男人说，“是吉米。你不记得了？”“吉米，”我喊道，完全惊呆了，“你看起来完全变了。我刚才差点直接走过你了。”除了胡子，他瘦了很多。可能是我的错觉，但我认为他长高了。
"What are you doing here," I asked. "I live here," he said. "Since when?" "Since about four years ago." I could not get over how different he looked. "I don't know lift weights anymore," he said. "I do tai chi. Lost a lot of bulk. Don't have muscles anymore. And I've gone vegetarian." "And you have the beard now," I chimed. "Yeah, my wife says it gives me authority." "Your wife?" "Can you believe it?" he said. "I got hitched."
“你在这干什么？”我问。“我住这儿，”他说。“什么时候开始的？”“大约四年前。”我无法相信他看起来有多大的不同。“我不再举重了，”他说，“我练太极。减轻了很多体重。没肌肉了。而且我吃素了。”“而且你现在还留了胡子，”我附和道。“是啊，我老婆说这让我更有威严。”“你老婆？”“你敢相信吗？”他说，“我结婚了。”
The whole episode was quite disorienting. Having Jimmy suddenly pop up in the middle of my Brighton after how many years? Five, was it? He asked me if I'd like to grab a bite. I said I would. I have to say, though, it was immediately comfortable between us. One thing about Jimmy and I, we always got along.
整件事让人非常迷惑。吉米在这么多年后——是五年吗？——突然出现在我的布莱顿中间。他问我想不想吃点东西。我说好。但我不得不说，我们之间立刻就感觉很自然。我和吉米有一点很好，我们一直合得来。
"I don't drink coffee anymore," he said. "Only herb tea. I'm watching my health, but I can have a chamomile tea and a tofu sandwich. I'm very strict." "Tofu sandwich," I said. "Oh, dear. I should be having a glass of wine, a pastry, a cappuccino, and a cigarette, in that order. Health kick." He laughed. "Oh, good," I thought. "I'm still amusing to him." While he wasn't looking, I glanced at the side of his face. He'd become quite beautiful, delicate almost. In the looks department, I have to say, the little bugger had really come into his own.
“我不再喝咖啡了，”他说，“只喝药草茶。我在注意健康，但我可以喝点洋甘菊茶，吃个豆腐三明治。我非常严格。”“豆腐三明治，”我说，“哦，天哪。我应该来杯红酒、点心、卡布奇诺，最后再来支烟，按这个顺序。什么健康饮食。”他笑了。“哦，真好，”我心想，“他依然觉得我很有趣。”在他不注意的时候，我瞥了一眼他的侧脸。他变得非常漂亮，几乎精致。在相貌方面，我不得不说，这个小家伙真的脱胎换骨了。
We went to an awful health restaurant where they had a lot of attitude and no pastry. And when I tried to light a cigarette, I got a lecture on secondhand smoke. He wanted me to meet his wife, thought the two of us would get along. "Why," I couldn't help wondering. "She reminds me of you," he said. "She's a bit older than me, very successful in business, has her own company. She trains executives how to speak in public and how to alter their image so they'll become a more effective tool in the marketplace." The whole enterprise sounded positively creepy. I asked him what his role in all this was. He said he videotaped the executives speaking and that Donna, the wife, would identify their weaknesses and therefore help to rectify them.
我们去了一家糟糕的健康餐馆，那里的服务员态度很傲慢，而且没点心。当我试图点烟时，还被上了一堂关于二手烟的课。他想让我见见他妻子，觉得我们两个会合得来。“为什么？”我不禁好奇。“她让我想起了你，”他说，“她比我大一点，事业非常成功，有自己的公司。她训练高管如何公开演讲，如何改变形象，让他们在市场上成为更有效的工具。”整个生意听起来真的很令人毛骨悚然。我问他在其中扮演什么角色。他说他负责把高管演讲的录像拍下来，然后唐娜——也就是他妻子——会指出他们的弱点，从而帮助他们改正。
"How old are you now," I asked, somewhat shifting the subject. "26," he said. "How old are you?" "I'm not telling you how old am," I said. "Let's put it this way. When I write down my date of birth now, I put the word circa next to it."
“你现在多大了？”我问，顺便转移了话题。“26岁，”他说，“你多大了？”“我不会告诉我的年龄的，”我说，“我们这么说吧，我现在写出生日期时，旁边会加上‘大约’这个词。”
Then he asked if I thought he seemed more mature. Apparently Donna was working on having him project a more mature version of himself. "Have you noticed I'm speaking slower," he asked. "Donna got me to do that. She made me watch a video of myself. I had no idea I talked so quickly." I'd never noticed it. Poor Jimmy was beginning to sound a bit like someone who's had a complete nervous breakdown and who's slowly pasting themselves back together again. And I was gaining the impression he'd married Eva Braun.
然后他问我，觉得他看起来是否更成熟了。显然唐娜正致力于让他展现出一个更成熟的自己。“你注意到我说话变慢了吗？”他问，“唐娜让我做到的。她让我看自己的录像。我根本不知道自己说话那么快。”我从来没注意过。可怜的吉米听起来有点像那种彻底精神崩溃、正在努力把自己一点点拼凑回去的人。而我开始觉得他娶了爱娃·布劳恩。
"She's not pointing any cameras at me," I thought, just as some horrendous-looking alfalfa something or other arrived. God knows what it was, but I wasn't going to eat it. He asked me how what's-his-name was. "You mean Keith," I said. "I have no idea. I haven't seen Keith for nearly two years. The last time I tried to talk to Keith, he said he still wasn't ready to speak to me yet." "Was it because of me," he asked, with a tone of slight self-satisfaction. I have to say, it did irritate me for a moment. I mean, there was a reason Keith and I stayed together for six years. It wasn't a complete waste of time. "Let's just say you didn't help."
“她没拿摄像机对着我，”我心想。就在这时，一些看起来惨不忍睹的紫花苜蓿之类的东西上桌了。天知道那是什么，但我可不打算吃。他问我某某人怎么样了。“你是说基思？”我说，“不知道。我有两年没见基思了。上次我试图跟基思说话，他说他还没准备好跟我交谈。”“是因为我吗？”他带着一丝自以为是的语气问。我必须承认，那一刻确实让我恼火。我的意思是，基思和我在一起六年是有原因的。那绝不是完全浪费时间。“只能说你没帮上什么忙。”
One thing about Keith, he could read me like a book. He immediately knew what had happened with Jimmy. "The way you talked about him in the store, it was obvious," he'd say. "It's sad," he'd go on. "You're like a little girl. You'll fall for anyone who flatters you." Keith always referred to the thing with Jimmy as the episode. "You haven't been the same person since the episode," was how he put it.
关于基思有一点，他看我就像看书一样。他立刻就知道了吉米发生的事。“你在店里谈论他的方式，太明显了，”他会说，“真可悲，”他继续说，“你就像个小女孩。你会爱上任何恭维你的人。”基思总是把吉米的事称为“那次插曲”。“自从那次插曲后，你就不是以前的你了，”他是这么说的。
I really didn't want to meet Donna. I imagined her as exuding sex appeal and confidence, and I really wasn't feeling up to comparisons. But I went along with it. For some reason, Jimmy was so eager for us to meet. He called her up, warned her we were on our way while I excused myself for an emergency one-on-one between myself and my face in the bathroom mirror. "I hope it's the light in here," I thought. "Either that, my dear, or it is time to lay off the lattes."
我真的不想见唐娜。我想象她一定散发着性感和自信，而我真的不想进行比较。但我还是去了。不知何故，吉米非常渴望我们见面。他给她打了电话，警告她我们正在去的路上，而我借口去洗手间镜子前做了一次紧急自我面容修复。“希望是因为光线，”我心想，“不然就是，亲爱的，你真的该少喝拿铁了。”
Donna was on a business call when we walked in, with her back to us. Well, she was nothing at all like I'd anticipated. Donna was a big girl. I mean literally. She must have been at least six feet two. And I have to say-- and this will sound awfully ungenerous on my part, and it is-- but the first thing that drew my attention was her hips. She's probably given birth to something, I presumed. When she turned around, I thought, "Oh, I'm much better looking than you." And I was sort of surprised at myself for how juvenile I was behaving. But I have to say, I did suddenly feel in the mood to be a little threatening.
我们走进去时，唐娜正在打业务电话，背对着我们。好吧，她和我预想的完全不同。唐娜是个大个子。我是说字面意思上的。她至少有一米八八。我不得不说——这听起来会让我显得很刻薄，事实也确实如此——但我注意到的第一件事是她的臀部。我想，她可能生过什么东西吧。当她转过身时，我想：“哦，我比你好看多了。”我自己都惊讶于自己竟然表现得这么幼稚。但我必须说，我突然有种想挑衅一下的冲动。
Finally she gets off the phone, waltzes over, extending her hand. "I'm sorry," she says. "The Americans just think I've got all the time in the world. But they're where the money is, so can't be complaining too much now, can we?" Then she kissed Jimmy on the mouth in front of me, which seemed a bit unnecessary, and said, "Hello, James." "James," I thought. "James. Well, excuse me." Jimmy may have been many things. One thing he wasn't was a James.
终于她挂了电话，优雅地走过来，伸出手。“对不起，”她说，“美国人总觉得我有大把的时间。但钱都在他们那儿，所以也不能太抱怨了，不是吗？”然后她在我的注视下吻了吉米的嘴，这看起来有点没必要，她说：“你好，詹姆斯。”“詹姆斯，”我想，“詹姆斯。好吧，打扰了。”吉米可能是个多种多样的人，但有一点他绝不是，他不是詹姆斯。
Redirecting her attention towards me, "What line are you in, Lillian," she asks. "Books," I say, "though I seldom read them." "Oh. Publishing," she says. "No," says I. "Secondhand mostly." "Oh," she says. "What a pretty shirt you're wearing." And I thought, "You cow."
她把注意力转回我身上，“你是干哪行的，莉莲？”她问。“书，”我说，“尽管我很少读它们。”“哦。出版业？”她说。“不，”我说，“主要卖二手书。”“哦，”她说，“你穿的衬衫真漂亮。”我心想：“你这贱货。”
I was only there for about 10 minutes, which was quite long enough. Donna said she had a meeting to go to. "Oh, AA?" I inquired. "Oh, you're hilarious," she said. "So are you," I replied, which got no response. She said she was going to Germany for the rest of the week and that James had the car. Every time she mentioned James, I had to think for a moment who she was talking about. "You two can get reacquainted," she said. "You don't need me around, now, do you?" For a second, it felt like she was throwing him at me.
我在那儿只呆了10分钟左右，已经足够久了。唐娜说她要去开个会。“哦，戒酒互助会？”我问。“你真幽默，”她说。“你也一样，”我回答，她没有回应。她说她这周剩下的时间要去德国，詹姆斯有车。每次她提到詹姆斯，我都要想一会儿她在说谁。“你们俩可以重温旧情，”她说，“不需要我在旁边，不是吗？”有一瞬间，感觉她像是要把他扔给我。
Jimmy wanted to give me a tour of the south coast. So the following day, after Donna left, he picked me up at the hotel. We went driving in her BMW. "What happened to your car?" I asked. "Donna made me get rid of it," he said. "I liked that car," I protested. "It suited you." "She approves of you," he said. "She thought you were down to earth," which, from a pretentious person, is not a compliment.
吉米想带我游览南海岸。所以第二天，唐娜走后，他开车来酒店接我。我们开着她的宝马。你的车呢？我问。“唐娜让我把它处理了，”他说。“我喜欢那辆车，”我抗议道，“它很适合你。”“她认可你，”他说，“她觉得你脚踏实地。”——这话从一个自命不凡的人嘴里说出来，可不是什么恭维。
"She said she thinks you're the kind of woman she could imagine me being with much more than her." "What does she mean by that?" I asked. "I don't know," he said. "Sometimes I think she's tired of being married to people." "I'm her fourth husband." "Oh," I said. Then we just go drove for a while without saying anything.
“她说她觉得你是我能想象到的，比她更适合在一起的那种女人。”“她是什么意思？”我问。“我不知道，”他说，“有时我觉得她厌倦了和人结婚。我是她的第四任丈夫。”“哦，”我说。然后我们就开车走了一会儿，谁也没说话。
The countryside along the south coast is lovely. I remembered how much I like to be in the passenger seat of a car. While Jimmy was driving, I happened to notice his hands on the steering wheel. They looked older. I looked at mine. I'm sure they do too. He slipped in a cassette tape. I lowered my window. A gust of wind blew through the car. My hair went everywhere. Care and all its relatives seemed to fall out of me. I don't know if it was the sea air or the music, too many cappuccinos or Jimmy, but I felt something like a sudden wave of enthusiasm. He must have thought my mind had just fluttered out the car window. "Right now," I explained, "I feel like I'm right in the world."
南海岸的风景很美。我记得我有多喜欢坐在汽车副驾驶的位置。吉米开车时，我无意中看到他放在方向盘上的手。它们看起来老了。我看了看自己的。我相信它们也老了。他塞进一盘磁带。我摇下车窗。一阵风吹进车里。我的头发被吹得乱七八糟。忧虑及其亲戚似乎从我身上消失了。我不知道是因为海风、音乐、喝了太多卡布奇诺还是吉米，但我感到一阵热情涌上心头。他一定以为我的心随风飘走了。“此刻，”我解释说，“我觉得自己就在这个世界上。”
Driving along the coast, we came to a huge fun fair. Jimmy wanted to get off the road and investigate. I did not take much convincing. As we were going in, he stopped in his tracks. "I always get excited around you," he said. I said, "I feel the same way." I realized what it was. You see, you can be romantic with Jimmy and not feel like a fool. I had been waiting a long time to be romantic with someone.
沿着海岸开，我们看到了一个巨大的游乐场。吉米想下车去探索一下。我没怎么推辞就同意了。进门的时候，他停下脚步。“在你身边我总是很兴奋，”他说。我说，“我感觉也一样。”我意识到那是什么了。你看，你可以和吉米浪漫而不觉得自己是个傻瓜。我等这一天等了很久。
Jimmy was immediately drawn to an enormous roller coaster called the Big Plunge. The Big Plunge was a ride that would go up extremely high and then plummet. Now, I have a terrible fear of heights. "There is no way you're going to get me up on that thing," I said. "You go if you want to. I'll stay here and have a cigarette." "Oh, Lillian, you're afraid of everything," he said. "How dare you?" I said. "I'm not." "Come on," he said. "Fear at a certain point just becomes another bad habit." Which had to have been something he'd picked up from Donna.
吉米立刻被一个巨大的过山车吸引住了，叫“大俯冲”。“大俯冲”是一个会升到极高处然后猛地坠落的游乐设施。现在，我特别恐高。“你不可能让我坐那个东西，”我说，“你想去就去吧。我就在这儿抽根烟。”“哦，莉莲，你什么都怕，”他说。“你竟敢？”我说，“我才没有。”“来吧，”他说，“恐惧到了某种程度就只是一种坏习惯。”这肯定是他在唐娜那里学到的。
The only way I could go on the Big Plunge was by going through a complicated psychological snow job in which I rationalize that my fear of heights actually represented my terror of life and that going on the Big Plunge was extremely important for me and could lead to a personal breakthrough. Besides if 10-year-old children could brave it, so could I. "I'm sure I'm the oldest person to ever take the plunge," I cried. The terrified wit.
我能坐上“大俯冲”的唯一方法，就是通过复杂的心理暗示，合理化说我对高度的恐惧实际上代表了我对生活的恐惧，坐这个对我来说非常重要，可能导致个人的突破。再说，如果10岁小孩都敢坐，我也可以。“我相信我是有史以来坐这个年纪最大的人了，”我大声说，这是我害怕时的自嘲。
As the ride yanked everyone forward and the squealing began, first off I was petrified. Then I seemed to push through the fear. I have to say, the whole thing did seem like a personal breakthrough. Donna would have been proud of me. Jimmy held my hand for the duration, which was sweet of him. I've never been able to go on those rides before, but I ended up loving it. Went on three more times. It had become completely easy between us.
当游乐设施向前猛冲，尖叫声响起时，我起初吓坏了。然后我似乎冲破了恐惧。我不得不说，整件事看起来确实像是一种个人突破。唐娜要是看到肯定会为我骄傲。吉米全程握着我的手，这真是太贴心了。我以前从没坐过这种设施，但最后我爱上了它。又坐了三次。我们之间变得完全轻松自如了。
Midway through the day, a strange notion crossed my mind. "I can imagine myself being with you for a long time," I thought. By late afternoon, I realized I really was getting a little lightheaded around Jimmy. I stood at a distance as he was buying tickets for the next ride and tried to give myself a little talking to. "He's 26. He's married. He lives in Brighton," I said to myself. "Lillian, stop it."
在这一天快结束时，一个奇怪的念头闪过脑海。“我可以想象自己和你在一起很长一段时间，”我想。到了傍晚，我意识到自己在吉米身边确实有点头晕目眩。在他买下一趟票时，我站在远处，试着给自己做了一番心理建设。“他26岁，他结婚了，他住在布莱顿，”我对自己说，“莉莲，别这样。”
Then out of the blue, on the Ferris wheel, he gives me a peck on the cheek. "What are you doing?" I asked, trying to not sound delighted and failing abysmally. "I wanted to kiss you," he says. "James," I scolded, "behave."
然后出人意料地，在摩天轮上，他在我脸颊上亲了一下。“你在干什么？”我问，努力不让自己表现出狂喜，但惨败了。“我想吻你，”他说。“詹姆斯，”我训斥道，“规矩点。”
The Ferris wheel then abruptly jolted to a halt, fortunately with us on the low end. While we were waiting to move, Jimmy came out with what seemed like an out of the blue question. "If somebody told you your life would end in, say, a year, do you think you'd start to really live or do you think you'd slip back under the covers and wait for it to be over?" "I think I'd get a move on," I replied. Just then the wheel began to turn. As we were passing the arcade, I noticed a photo booth. "I don't have any pictures of you," I said. "Come on. I need some proof that you exist."
摩天轮突然猛地停住了，幸好我们在底部。在我们等待移动时，吉米问了一个突如其来的问题。“如果有人告诉你，你的生命只剩下一年，你觉得你会开始真正生活，还是会躲回被子里等待结束？”“我想我会立刻行动起来，”我回答。就在那时轮子开始转动。当我们经过拱廊时，我注意到一个照相亭。“我一张你的照片都没有，”我说，“来吧，我需要证明你真实存在。”
We were clowning around in front of the camera. Pictures took forever to come out. When they finally did emerge from the machine, I wasn't quite prepared for what I saw. What took me back about the photos was that we looked like two people who were completely in love with each other.
我们在镜头前耍宝。照片洗出来花了好久。当它们最终从机器里出来时，我对自己所看到的感到有点措手不及。让我惊讶的是，照片里看起来就像是一对正完全坠入爱河的人。
It's a year later. Lillian and Jimmy are married and happy.
一年后。莉莲和吉米结婚了，生活得很幸福。
He had next to nothing in the way of possessions. Everything had belonged to Donna. One of the few things that was actually his was this little tent that he took everywhere just in case he ever felt the urge to sleep outside, he'd say. One Saturday, we took a bus ride into the country. Sure enough, little package came along too. No sooner we're off the bus than Jimmy said, "Let's forget about going home. I want to sleep under the sky." I have to say, the idea did appeal. So we bought some sandwiches and supplies, walked what must have been miles till we found this spot that met Jimmy's definition of the word remote, by which time the sky was quite black. He set up a little tent and pulled out a sleeping bag he'd had all along.
他几乎一无所有。一切都是唐娜的。他为数不多的私人物品之一是这个小帐篷，他去哪都带着，说万一哪天想露宿街头就用得着。一个星期六，我们坐公交车进城。果不其然，小包裹也跟着去了。刚下车，吉米就说：“别回去了，我想睡在天空下。”不得不说，这个想法很吸引人。于是我们买了些三明治和补给品，走了好几英里，直到找到一个符合吉米所谓“偏远”定义的地点，当时天空已经全黑了。他搭了个小帐篷，拿出他一直带在身边的睡袋。
By the time we'd eaten, it was late. Jimmy went pretty much straight to sleep. I, on the other hand, just laid there. The ground was uneven to put it mildly. I think we were parked on top of a mole community. My spine was wondering what the hell was going on, and it was damp. But I didn't care. It was so quiet in the open. You could almost hear your moods change. If you laid still enough, you could feel your instincts wriggling to the surface.
等我们吃完，天已经晚了。吉米很快就睡着了。我却一直躺着。地面很不平坦，说得委婉点。我想我们是停在一个鼹鼠社区的顶部。我的脊椎在想这到底是怎么回事，而且地面很潮湿。但我不在乎。户外太安静了。你几乎能听到你情绪的变化。如果你躺得够平，你甚至能感觉到你的本能正在蠕动浮现。
Hours go by, and I'm still wide awake, thinking, "I'm 41 years old. It's 3 o'clock in the morning. And I'm laying in a field." And the whole thing seemed so absurd. I just started laughing. "You know what?" I thought. "Good things are going to happen. I'm ready for them now. I wasn't before. I am now." "Yes," I thought. "I'm ready to roll my sleeves up. My sleeves are fairly twitching to be rolled for the good things."
几个小时过去了，我依然清醒着，心想：“我41岁了。现在是凌晨3点。我躺在田野里。”整件事看起来如此荒谬。我不禁笑了起来。“你知道吗？”我想，“好事要发生了。我现在准备好了。以前没有，现在准备好了。”“是的，”我想，“我准备好卷起袖子了。我的袖子都在为好事而跃跃欲试。”
David Cale's one woman show Lillian premiered at the Goodman Studio Theatre in Chicago. It was directed by Joe Mantello. They're currently in the process of putting the show up in other cities. Watch for it. It's really great.
大卫·凯尔的单人秀《莉莲》在芝加哥古德曼工作室剧院首演。由乔·曼特洛执导。他们目前正在筹划在其他城市巡演。留意一下。真的很棒。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Senior editor Paul Tough.
今天的节目由南希·厄普代克、我自己、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德共同制作。资深编辑保罗·塔夫。
To buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago. Our phone number 312-832-3380. Our email address [email protected] . This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如需购买本节目磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ。电话号码是312-832-3380。电子邮箱[email protected]。《这就是美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who's not trying to escape any boxes.
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚，他可不想逃离任何盒子。
I just have to try to put this in a little box like I have every other thing that has been said and done and go on and do my job. That's what I'm going to work at.
我必须试着把这一切像其他所有的言行一样放进一个小盒子里，然后继续做好我的工作。这就是我要努力的方向。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《这就是美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。